good morning everyone labour has secured
a surprise victory in the battle and
spend by-election
with kem uh kim ledbeter holding off the
conservative challenge
mrs ledbetter who is the sister of the
murdered mp joe cox says the
constituency rejected division
and voted for hope uh that was after an
ill-tempered campaign
zakir starmer whose leadership of labor
is under scrutiny described it as a
fantastic result
for a brilliant and brave candidate
this is the final result labour's kim
ledbeter won
13 296
votes beating the conservative candidate
ryan stevenson's total
of 12 973
and here is the vote share labor won
35.3
the conservatives 34.4 george galloway's
workers party
workers party of britain came third with
21.9
of the vote both of the top two parties
vote share was
down on the last election well our chief
political correspondent john craig
reports
i do hereby declare that kim michelle
ledbeter is duly elected
a win against the odds for labour's kim
ledbeter
after a bitter and divisive campaign and
immense relief for an embattled sakir
stama
the focus now is catching up on a bit of
sleep um
maybe having a few glasses of fizz um
and then there's lots to do
and i think the campaign has highlighted
that there's lots to do
but i'm going to crack on with it and i
will do my very best
to represent the whole of batley and
spain as their new mp
i'm absolutely delighted that the people
of batley and spen have rejected
division and they've voted for hope
thank you very much everybody clinging
on to the seat
previously held by her sister joe cox
will ease the pressure on the labour
leader who was facing calls to quit
if his party had lost but george
galloway who came
third is now threatening to challenge
the result
in the courts we have been
multiply defamed to the point that
i'm no longer prepared to talk with the
mainstream media which is why
i'm talking to you now by this live
stream
the whole election campaign was
dominated by lazy
and false tropes about our campaign
about the thousands of people that voted
for us
about their motives for doing so in a
way which
defamed them as much as it defamed
me during a night of
drama before the result was declared
after 5am
tory mps denied they were taking victory
for granted
and after the result conservative
sources said ms ledbeter's victory
was not a labour win but a labour hold
within the past two months british
politics has been turned
upside down with three sensational
by-election results
first the tory's victory in hartlepool
on may the
sixth second a spectacular liberal
democrat triumph
in the true blue tory heartland of
cheshire and amisham
and now here in west yorkshire labour
have clung on
against all the odds in battley and
spain
so sakia lives to fight another day but
from his lead beater and her supporters
it's time to celebrate john craig sky
news
huddersfield joining us now is the
conservative party co-chair amanda
milling hello to you thanks for joining
us
this morning you were favorites to win
why didn't you so it's a really
disappointing result but
first of all i want to pay tribute to
ryan stevenson who's been an absolutely
fantastic candidate he's worked
his heart out day in and day out and
also to congratulate kim
but this was always going to be a really
tough battle for us
we didn't win this in 2019 governing
parties don't
tend to win by-elections and we have to
be clear on this
this is a labour hold not a labour game
not a way we were
favorites to win i mean the polls were
suggesting that you would get 47 percent
of the vote you got 34 percent why do
you think that is
one thing i would always say about
elections there's only one poll that
matters and that's the one on the day
you know we fought a really hard
campaign but
what i would say it was a very very
close result
you know as and as i say um governing
parties don't win by elections they
certainly don't gain by elections you
certainly lost two on the bounds haven't
you
so each of these by-elections is a
unique challenge
um it was really disappointing to lose
cheshire amisham
but you know we had we fought a really
um hard fight but let's be really clear
about this this is not a
great win for the labour party you know
this was
we really kind of took the fight to them
they only won by
a matter of just over three hundred
because they said the polls were
suggesting that you're going to win
easily
um it's the hancock effect isn't it so
there's a whole load of issues that
affected you know our campaign it's lots
of issues that come up on the doorstep
you know we fought a really hard
campaign i'm really disappointed and
particularly disappointed for ryan
um but you know at the end of the day
you know this wasn't a great result for
labour
you have to concede that the behavior of
your former health secretary must have
had
some impact on people in batley and spen
who are honest hard-working people
and don't like the way he behaved so you
know it was something that came up on
the doorstep i have to be honest about
that
but then lots of different what did they
say
they had some issues until over the
weekend in terms of
you know what happened but matt resigned
and that was the right thing to do
but there's a whole host of different
issues that came up but we also need to
remember that
governing parties don't gain
by-elections
and actually taking it to such a small
number of votes
in itself was a tremendous result quite
extraordinary i would say so the people
in battle and spain
uh at the weekend were saying uh we
don't like the way that
uh that he behaved and i'm guessing they
also weren't particularly pleased with
the way that the prime minister said the
case is closed in a very superior manner
so you know matt did the right thing at
the weekend which was to resign
and within 24 hours of the story
breaking we had a new health secretary
and sanji javi's doing a tremendous job
he's literally
going to work out from day one because
at the end of the day we're still in the
middle of this pandemic we've got a job
to do to ensure that we
roll out these vaccines so that we can
then open up the country and get back to
life as normal er
any answer to my question what were
people saying about the prime minister
at the weekend
so they you know there's a lot of love
for the prime minister you know he gets
a tremendous
a lot of support on the doorstep and you
know as i say
you know matt did the right thing to
resign and within 24 hours we had new
health secretary
yeah a lot of love on the doorstep
didn't translate to a win though did it
um let's talk about matt hancock um what
has what's happened as far as the
investigation is concerned into his
behavior
so the mata for investigation is
something that i'm you know
i'm not here to discuss this morning the
thing is we had a by-election we've just
had a result in yeah we've dealt with
that we've dealt with that why is there
no investigation into matt hancock
you're the co-party chair
so i don't talk about investigations why
not understand
so as i say i'm not going to get drawn
into any kind of discussions in terms of
investigation
we should know what's happening as far
as the former health secretary is
concerned
he was snogging his aid in his office
when he was supposed to be dealing with
a pandemic
tried to hang on prime minister said the
matter was closed the british public
said
hang on a minute as a result he stepped
down we should know
what's happening as far as the
investigation is concerned so surely it
has to be transparent surely it does
so in terms of all i would say is this
morning i'm here with on the back of a
by-election result
you know we have literally two and you
actually touch and you have knowledge
and you acknowledge as part of that by
election it was the behavior of the
former health secretary that cost you
that's a lot of different issues so i'm
asking you as a follow-up question what
happened
in relation to the investigation so
there was a lot of different issues that
came up on the doorstep
and actually let's look at this result
it was incredibly good you know we were
really so close
and governing parties shouldn't be
within a whisker
of gaining and by-election yeah you were
close but as you said there's only one
result that matters and you lost
um as far as him employing his mistress
at taxpayers expense
what's happening as far as that's
concerned so there are you know some of
these matters are matters for
uh the government and you know no no no
no they're matters for the public
they want to know about uh the former
health secretary
paying his mistress fifteen thousand
pounds
of taxpayers money what are you doing
about it so there are processes that we
go through in terms of in terms of
appointments and that all the processes
work
gone through um in accordance to to
those and so
you know so i think that kind of answers
your question well it doesn't i have a
follow-up if i may
did you know that he was paying his
mistress
fifteen thousand pounds so like i say um
there was a story that broke last week
i didn't know any of the details of that
but there are due process
in terms of these appointments and those
processes we've gone through and does
that due process
allow for a minister to pay fifteen
thousand pounds to his mistress
so this this is a story which you know
matt has rightly resigned
he um recognized that he he did wrong
and that you know we now need to move on
we in the middle of a pandemic
sagittarian is taken on as a health
secretary he's doing a tremendous job
because what we need to do right now
when they're stood in the middle of this
pandemic we need to get these vaccines
rolled out
in order to be able to get the country
back to normal yeah
however we don't move on until we find
out why he was paying his mistress
fifteen thousand pounds to snog in his
office
but he was that was an appointment was
made through due process well how can it
be
through due process when he was paying
his mistress
whatever process you look at by whatever
measure that is not acceptable
to the british public to the extent
where you've lost a by-election
so i know the public will be incredibly
frustrated because at the end of the day
we have all made a huge number of
sacrifices
um you know we are we want to get back
to normal
but matt did the right thing by
resigning so is the matter closed now is
that what you're saying he's
now resigned so i would see that as kind
of the matter is closed
so there is no investigation as i say
you know matt has done the right thing
in terms of resigning and you know i
understand the public
uh been deeply frustrated by
um kind of all of the issues that we
faced over the last 12 months the
sacrifices they've made
but you know i want us to all pull
together as we
kind of get those vaccines rolled out so
that we can get the country back
up and running will there be an
investigation or not as i say you know i
think the matter is closed now matt has
so there won't be an investigation into
our health secretary during the middle
of a global pandemic
where we've lost 120 000 people uh just
in the united kingdom
he's spent some of his time paying his
mistress fifteen thousand pounds a year
taking her on g7 trips up to birmingham
and snogging her in his office
the matter is closed as far as that's
concerned no investigation has
you know that he broke the law so the
you know matt resigned at the weekend
he is no longer the health secretary and
you know now
our focus has got to be on getting those
vaccines rolled out
and getting the country back he broke
the law
i think that you know people have made
mistakes using the uk in terms of
um the the rules during the course of uh
the last 12 months as you know yourself
and so you know i think matt has
resigned the law
matt has resigned and you know so there
should be no come back as far as uh the
health secretary is concerned and he
should be welcomed back
to uh government within the course of a
year which is apparently what he's
planning to do
well the matter for kind of who is
appointed to ministerial positions as a
matter for the prime minister
you know right now mike did the right
thing by resigning
and the fact that he broke the law that
that's the matter closed like as i say
people have broken the rules okay
as you well know and
as you know you've made the point twice
as you know i was sanctioned
i was off here for six months uh i don't
make policy
you do and he certainly did at the time
does he have to face any comeback as a
result of breaking the law
during a global pandemic and um snogging
with his
uh assistance he did not exist he did
the wrong thing
he recognizes that and he resigned and
that was the right thing for him to do
okay is there going to be an
investigation as i say
you know matt has resigned is there
going to be an investigation
matt has resigned and you know we've now
got a new health secretary
and you know we have got to focus now on
whether or not you know getting this
country back up and running getting
these
vaccines rolled down okay so when he was
supposed to be making policy
uh and when he was rolling out these uh
uh inoculations
and 120 000 people died and when he was
telling people that they couldn't hug
their grandmother before they died
um all of that while he was also having
a relationship
with his aide in his office and also
paying that aid 15 000 pounds of tax
payers money
that doesn't warrant an investigation so
look i can understand why the public
would be
deeply frustrated we have all made so
many sacrifices people up and down the
country who haven't been able to be with
their loved ones
and and that matt has resigned he
recognized he did wrong
and you know the public um
understandably are frustrated yeah they
are
that's why you've lost a by-election the
reason why you're sitting here this week
this morning and saying it doesn't
matter
so we didn't lose by election you said
it was brought up on the doorsteps
what happened is that labor held the
seat
they held the seat only by a whisker you
were you were
this is not a great success for the
labour party and why is it for you
and why it's not a loss for us because
we didn't gain the seat it wasn't ours
to lose it was a labour party's to lose
okay it's good to talk to you i'm sorry
we're going to have to leave it there i
look forward to
you coming back very soon indeed thank
you uh going to be speaking
to the journalist who broke the story
that kim
ledbeter was running for the batlin
spence seat very shortly
indeed that's dominic brown he is on the
show in just
a few moments time
also what next for the labour party the
party's national campaign coordinator
shabana mahmoud mp joins us at five past
eight and then at half past nine
we are going to be speaking to the woman
who was on the diamond princess cruise
ship as it was struck by covid
last year
[Music]
returning now to our top story and the
victory in the battley and spend
by-election which saw the party cling
onto its seat
with a narrow majority of 323
uh kim ledbetter was victorious she is
now the mp for batley and spen and she
is joining us now hello to you
good morning k good morning to you how
proud would your sister be of you this
morning
she'd be incredibly proud joe always
used to say to me you need to push
yourself more you need to challenge
yourself
more and she would be extremely proud
you thank the police in your victory
speech
how nasty was the campaign for you
sadly we had some pretty ugly scenes
last weekend
during the campaign i was subjected to
personal abuse and intimidation and
sadly people who were helping me with a
campaign
had similar um i think even someone got
even arrested
and it's really sad that we had that
because i tried to conduct a really
positive campaign
full of energy all about the people of
batley and spain
so it was very upsetting to see that
kind of divisiveness creeping into our
politics
again how disappointed were you
not to have a much bigger majority i
mean 3
23 is is how many you won by i mean
with 323 you could have lost by 323
couldn't you it's not a resounding
success
a win is a win and i'll take that every
day of the week it was always going to
be close
you know apollo 6 is tough at the minute
um but i think i i'm really pleased with
the win that we've had
uh we were chatting to amanda milling i
don't know if you if you heard her a
second or two ago conservative party
co-chair and she admitted that the matt
hancock effect
had uh had an impact on their vote is
that what you were hearing on the on the
doorstep do you know what
the vast majority of conversations i've
had with people have been about local
issues
and i think lots of people have tried to
make this about
other things that are going on at a
national level but what most people in
batlin spain wanted
was an mp who is local who cares about
this area and understands
the issues that they're concerned about
and because i live here and i've lived
here all my life i think that really
resonated with people
why does george galloway do so well
i think we've got communities across
bali and spain
who um are sadly a bit disillusioned
with politics
and disillusioned with traditional sort
of politicians
um one of the things i really want to
focus on is
how we get people engaged with politics
in a positive way
and i think sometimes you know we've had
people come here this by election with
their own agendas and their own egos
and i've played into people's
frustrations
my job now is to bring those people
together around a shared vision for a
prosperous
and bright future for batley and sven he
says he's going to contend the result
what do you contest the result what do
you think
listen i'm focused on the rest of my day
which is celebrating with an amazing
team
who have supported me throughout this
campaign uh getting back in touch with
my family and friends who i've barely
seen during the last few weeks
and then cracking on with the job of
being the mp for ballet and spain
yeah i mean he did take 22 percent of
the vote didn't he and that was on an
anti-labor stance it does look as though
uh much of the
muslim community as was uh supporting
him
rather than you what do you need to do
to bring them back into the field
i've spent the last few years working
for the jura cox foundation uh building
communities across badly in spain and
indeed at a national level
um and i'll continue to do that and i
think sadly the divisive nature of
other people's campaigns um means that
that word
work still needs to be done but if
anyone can do it then i believe that i
can do it
supported by the you know the majority
of people in battle and spain who just
want to live together peacefully
send their kids to school have a good
nhs look after their elderly relatives
and
you know and and just get on with their
lives and i think that's what we all
want to do now you know we've had
a lot of attention in badly and spending
the last few weeks indeed in the last
few years
and i think we just need now a bit of
stability and hopefully i can be part of
that
and what do the people of batley and
spend think of kia stammer
again most of the conversations i've had
with people have been very very
localized
uh keir's coming up later on today and
it'll be wonderful to celebrate with him
um so i think you know let's move
forward now as a labour party
with ciara at the helm with me as the
new mp for batley and spen and i think
have that sense of togetherness within
the party
that we've had during this campaign
because it's been really really powerful
and i have been so well supported by
this party
um and the values of the labor party
that have connected with people i think
given us the victory
around you know equality and fairness
and social justice i think
you know there's a piece of work to be
done but i feel really proud to be part
of that
um what's the first thing that you plan
to do when you come to the palace of
westminster
um i need to meet all the many people
who have supported me during this
campaign you know i've had so many
labour mps have come up here to
to meet me and and support me so i want
to i want to go down and say a massive
thank you to them
and then i want to crack on with the
work you know and that really is
is about getting on with the issues that
people have raised on the doorsteps
looking at how that plays out at a local
level
at a national level um so there's a lot
to be done once i've said thank you to
all the many people who've helped me
once i've seen my family and friends
then you know i'm going to hit the
ground running
yeah i'm just looking at the number of
elections that the people of batley and
spen have had to deal with five
elections in the
past six years um it's been quite a
roller coaster for them is it going to
be a bit more stable now
i really do hope so okay as someone who
lives here
you know we have been through the mill
um and it is destructive
you know and like i say we've got a
lovely selection of towns and villages
across batley and spain where where
people just want to get on with their
lives and
when the media descends and when people
from out of this area descend
it is disruptive it's not good for
people so i'm really hoping that
we have a period of calm we have a
period of stability and and my role as
our mp will
will be pivotal in that but you know the
people around here are just amazing the
conversations i've had with people of
this
campaign have been so powerful and you
know i'm really looking forward to
working
together with them on what matters to
our towns and villagers
what did your parents say when or what
did the family say
when you said that you wanted to to run
as an mp given what happened to joe in
such a tragic way when she was
representing the people of batlin spain
it was a big team decision it was a big
family decision
um but you know mum and dad have seen
the work that i've done through the
foundation
they've seen the network that i've got
across our local area
and how powerful that can be and a way
to build on that work
is by being our mp and they were very
very supportive of that and they always
said as well you know
if you don't do it you might regret not
going for it you know whatever whatever
happens
um and yeah it was a team decision and
it's very emotional for us as a family
of course it is um
but listen if i can be half the mp that
joe was then i'll be very very happy and
very very proud of that
and will there be parts of joe that you
want to bring
to westminster do you i mean obviously
we know that you're
joe's sister you also want to be your
own person when you come to the palace
of westminster
but are there uh characteristics of her
that you'll bring along with you for
your maiden speech for example
yeah i mean i'm kim ledbeter i am joe
cox's sister and that's how lots of
people know me and i've never been more
proud to be so but i am doing this job
very much as me uh one thing i would say
though is the way that joe worked on a
cross-party basis i think is something
which i
always admired and respected and i think
we don't do enough of that and we don't
talk enough about that you know the mps
that i've met and know
a lot of cross-party work goes on behind
the scenes but because it always isn't
as quite as controversial as some of the
other stuff it doesn't get covered in
the way that
it maybe should do so i'll be looking to
work on a cross-party basis
with anybody who who is happy to do that
on the issues that matter to the people
of batley and sven and the issues that
mattered more broadly to the country
now a quick look at the front pages
which of course went to print before we
had that result from batley
and spen and the telegraph to start with
has the pm's plea for patience as kobe
disruption in schools continues
the express leads on boris johnson's
warning that some covid restrictions may
need to continue
after the 19th of july the mirror
goes with princess william and harry
unveiling the statue of their mother
princess diana in the sunken garden
of kensington palace the male sees it
somewhat differently
together but still so far apart
and the guardian has scientists warning
nowhere is safe from the extreme heat
events that have hit
the western u.s and canada time for a
look at the morning's other main story
as we know here on sky president biden
has traveled to florida to meet families
and first responders
at the site of the collapsed miami
apartment block mr biden praised the
efforts of the emergency services
searching through the wreckage
and spoke of how the incident resonated
with his own
previous experiences of loss
i sat with one woman who had just
lost her her husband and her little baby
boy
didn't know what to do i sat with
another family that lost
almost an entire family cousins brothers
sisters
and to watch them and the the their
their
praying and pleading that god
that to be a miracle let there be
something happen for me that's good
because i have like many of you do some
idea what it's like to suffer that kind
of loss
so many of them are suffering
roy scouts of america association has
agreed a record settlement in court with
victims of historic
child sex abuse attorneys representing
more than
60 000 victims reached an 850 million
pounds
dollar i should say agreement with the
association the largest in a child
sexual abuse case in
american history
virgin boss richard branson is to take a
ride aboard his own virgin galactic into
space
later this month the unity 22 mission
will be the first to carry a full crew
of two pilots and four passengers
to test the private astronaut experience
the 90-minute flight will go into space
for 20 seconds
the company says it aims to make space
travel accessible
to all if you can afford the ticket
price of 180 000 pounds
back down to earth with a bomb don't
know nas is here what's the weather
doing now's good morning
good morning um it's looking pretty
unsettled as we head into the weekend
and today
we will see sunny spells it will be warm
but there will be some showers for some
too
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning low pressure out in the
atlantic is going to bring some rather
unsettled conditions across much of the
uk island through
this weekend and into the start of the
new week in the way of heavy showers as
well
as more persistent spells of rain and
strong winds until then today doesn't
look
too bad it's not going to be a
completely dry day though there will
still be some showers around and in fact
this morning the showery rain across
the southeast scotland northeast england
and a little light rain around eastern
parts of england otherwise mainly dry
but cloudy and murky the mist and frog
lifting and clearing though to sunny
spells this afternoon but there will be
showers scattered around
mainly around eastern parts of wales
northern east england southern scotland
then rain to the southwest later
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
our top story for you this morning
labour's kim ledbeter has pulled off a
surprise victory in the
battley and spen by-election in the last
half hour
uh this is what the co-chair of the
conservative party
had to say you know it was something
that came up on the doorstep i have to
be honest about that
but then lots of different what did they
say
they had some issues until over the
weekend in terms of um
you know what happened but matt resigned
and that was the right thing to do
but there's a whole host of different
issues that came up but we also need to
remember that
governing parties don't gain
by-elections
and actually taking it to such a small
number of votes
in itself was a tremendous result
so admitting there that uh what happened
with matt hancock did
play out in batley and spend it was
brought up he said
on the doorstep let's ask a dominic
brown editor of battley and versatile
news the first paper to share news of
mrs ledbeter's candidacy hello to you uh
dom it's good to talk to you thanks so
much indeed for joining us
uh we heard from the the party co-chair
there for the conservatives
saying matt hancock was an issue do you
think it was
i don't think i probably didn't help the
conservative
campaign care but um um
we had the prime minister in town a
couple of times
in the past a couple of weeks um making
some
some pretty big pledges um especially in
industry in terms of further education
and and in battery as well where he was
very keen to
pledge into investing skills and i think
those policies would probably
have gone down pretty well in in in
valley i imagine there's
there were probably quite a few voters
in valley and spain who have been
looking
down the road at neighbouring dewsbury
um with all the
the government money that's being plowed
into the town center regeneration
and with lots of projects coming on the
pipeline in the next few years
and thinking we'd like some of that um
so i i i it probably
probably wouldn't have helped the
campaign but um
it still was a very very tight result in
the end wasn't it overnight
it sure was um were you surprised
it's too close to call for us came and
we were here in various stories from
from out on the trail
um some people thinking the current
services would take it some people
thinking that that kim would win it for
labor
um it's a very diverse constituency is
about the unspent you look at the makeup
of
the area on them on the local council on
kirkleese council
and it's got it's got labor strongholds
on the council it's got conservatives on
board and it's got to leave them
strongholding click eaton so
um it's it's a diverse area and for one
party to to gather everyone together
at an mp level i think it would it would
be a an impressive effort
um which probably shows in the result
overnight while i was so close
yeah kim ledbetter thanking the police
after her win it was certainly bad
tempered at times wasn't it
i don't think anyone's liked to see some
of the images that have come out
on the campaign um but um
you know there were also scenes which i
think spread lots of hope in the area
and that there was a big rally in
battletown centre on saturday where
hundreds of people uh joined in the town
centre to stand up to racism and all
sorts of
of hatred um you know some some lovely
quotes from people where we had one of
the badly counselors
you know saying the importance of
standing up to these issues and saying
the town just will not be divided
um and then we had some other people
saying you know
actually said that the leaders trade
council who was also there on the day
you know saying how badly this was a
great welcoming place and they intended
to keep it that way
and the the message was there strong and
clear at the weekend
um ryan stevenson who was the
conservative candidate uh had been
accused of being invisible during the
campaign
uh what would you put that down to was
it because the conservatives saw i mean
according to the polls the conservatives
thought it was theirs
um did he think that he didn't have to
do too much to win or
what what do you think
um i mean ryland's inexperienced
local councillor on on on leeds city
council
means you know he's been in local
politics for a while
um and um you know it does two big
hitting visits from
from boris johnson in in in recent weeks
um and um
it's it was it was always going to be
tough going up against somebody like kim
and
she's she's a very very well known local
candidate
very well known person um it's a very
telling comment when kiestama was in
town
at the um early on in june okay when
he met with kim at one of the local
hotels for a meal
and he said afterwards when he was
speaking to us that he was genuinely
struck by
how many people came up to say hello to
him and how many people knew her
um and that was something that really
resonated with him like you can't go far
in bali in spain without somebody
knowing kim
um she's she's you've been talking about
in the community or in the last five
years involved in so many things
um she was always going to be a very
tough candidate for any other parties to
take on i think uh okay
um do you think she will be able to
increase that
uh uh no i mean it's a sliver majority
at the next election or do you think uh
george galloway has got his teeth into
badly in spend now and he'll be back
he's contesting
the results isn't he so i hear yes
um um
i think i think the did the turnout care
was interesting overnight it was
less than 50 percent you do wonder if if
you know if an element of
voter fatigue is setting in it was that
the fifth parliamentary election in the
last six years in badly unspent
um i think what what the constituency
needs really is
is a period of stability now um
where we have um an mp um
who's at the helm and it's it's such a
key moment not just for batman spend but
for the whole country as we hopefully
emerge from the final lockdown
restrictions in a few weeks time
um there's lots of issues that the
country as a whole will face
post pandemic and i think this you know
a period of stability
is is much needed okay great to talk to
you you've not been to sleep either have
you
i'm sure you're looking forward to your
bed
absolutely okay good to talk to you
thanks a lot
all right rob powell is in huddersfield
uh for us
this morning um hello to you rob
goodness me it could have been a much
tighter race than that could it
yeah very tight k um and a surprise as
well it's not what some of the polling
um
had shown 323 votes in it
i think what is making the labour team
um
here in yorkshire more chipper is the
fact that george galloway took 8 000
votes and they still managed
to win and what they are pointing out is
that they were making inroads
in some areas where they don't always
pick up too much
support and that if george galloway
hadn't stood and those 8 000 votes went
elsewhere then actually that win would
have been
a lot more uh comfortable now of course
there's
national trends national political
trends that have been projected
onto this by election but actually the
team here uh saying local issues
mattered a lot as well things like an
amazon warehouse that was going to be
built
um within the constituency that kim
ledbeter
was against nationally though of course
this does buy kierstama
a little bit of breathing space the
messaging coming out from some labor
sources today is that
whilst detractors of the leader were
saying this would be a referendum on his
leadership they are quoting that back
now and saying
well if that's the case uh we won but
this is not a resounding
win it's a very very tight win um we
will have to see
uh uh when this next when this comes up
for election next
where the george galloway stands and
whether they can increase the amount of
votes they have i think for the
conservatives
there will be a degree of frustration
and disappointment
there was accusations that the
conservative candidate here was really
standing back from the fray and hoping
that labour and george galloway
destroyed each other so he could come
through the middle and was somewhat
invisible
criticism as well of the get out the
vote campaign but a big challenge now i
think that kim led beta after this
divisive election to bring everyone
together
and be a voice for them in westminster
when joe white went to wembley on
tuesday they came away with more than
just the result to celebrate joe who is
non-binary and
identifies as queer posted on social
media about how welcome they felt while
wearing makeup in the stands
their tweet was even picked up by a
member of england's
victorious squad either bennett reports
when joe white posted this selfie after
england beat germany it was to celebrate
not the victory on the pitch but one off
it
lgbt it was the first time joe who
identifies as queer
had been to wembley in full makeup a big
step given their past experience of
homophobia in the stands
but tuesday was very different people
complimenting me on
my eyeshadow and my glitter
england flag that i did with some silver
eyeshadow and lipstick and my shoes
and it was just all really really
positive and absolutely no issues
joe's positive experience was then
shared by england midfielder jordan
henderson
who wrote hi joe great to hear you
enjoyed the game as you should
no one should be afraid to go and
support their club or country because
football is for everyone no matter what
having a an international player
use their platform to highlight
positives and
that football is for everyone is
something that i think we can all
endorse and he's not the only one
england captain harry kane wore a
rainbow armband during the win over
germany
to mark the end of pride month it's
clear football has come a long
way in recent years in terms of
inclusivity the slogans here outside
wembley for example
are all about community and diversity
but words are one thing of course
actions are another
only last week uefa refused a request by
the german fa to light up a stadium in
rainbow colours for a match against
hungary
because they said of the political
motives i can't say for a minute that
we've actually solved it i don't think
we'll ever solve it
pitter is a founding member of stonewall
fc the first gay
football club in britain how long do you
reckon before we have an openly gay
current premiership footballer how
long's a piece of string
a footballer's career is very very short
and it's about making
you know as much money as you can so
a lot of players are probably thinking
gay players
who are actually playing will probably
say you know what this is too much of a
risk and
i don't really want to be that
experiment to see what happens
if i do come out
[Applause]
but for the fans and amateur players who
have come out things are only getting
more inclusive
so that the beautiful game is beautiful
for all
iva bennett sky news wembley back to our
top story this morning which
is of course that the sister of the
murdered mp joe cox has pulled off a
surprise victory
in the batley and spend by-election kim
ledbeter won her seat by just 323 votes
in what turned out to be one of the most
bitterly fought parliamentary
by-election campaigns
in living memory well joining us now to
get some reaction
is the conservative peer and pollster as
well lord hayward hello to you lord
haywood thank you for joining us on the
program this morning
um it was looking high it was looking
like a nailed on win for the
conservatives what went wrong
i think essentially the people in batley
and spain were keeping their views to
themselves
uh there was obviously a lot of
confusion as to the amount of
impact that george galloway would have
um and
in the end the labour party held onto a
seat
with a small majority so not sure it
went wrong but it's
clearly disappointing for the tory party
and a great relief for kia stammer
we heard from the i don't know if you
saw my interview a half an hour or so
ago with the
uh co-chair of the party she said that
hancock came up on the doorstep
yes i with a small majority
small defeat like this you can always
point to things which
made a difference and i think uh
it's reasonable for people to say well
uh with a small majority
this might have influenced the results
and
potentially the way that the prime
minister tried to close it down by
saying the matters closed
oh i think it's a combination of both
sides it's not just matt hancock it is
uh a decision of the prime minister
because of the
the apparent delay in taking action
uh so if when you lose an election
particularly by a small margin you can
point to all sorts of different things
but clearly that will be something that
will come up so
how do you interpret that how does the
conservative party interpret that how
does the government interpret that
do they re do they have to think we
can't take
the uh public for granted uh even though
we do have a stonking majority in the
house of commons
i'm not sure that you could accuse them
of taking them for granted but certainly
there are messages there for the tory
party
the supposition that every brick in a
red wall is going to fall
automatically has clearly been put to
bed
they're going to have to campaign
continuing the leveling up process
but at the same time there will be
pressures from conservative pmbs in the
south
to say look you know we lost cheshire
and amisham a fortnight ago
so please pay attention to us it's not
easy when you get
a disappointing result but in the
circumstances
it's a it's a labor seat but
expectations had been built up
that's too on the balance though isn't
it
it is but they're in very different sets
of circumstances
and uh therefore they have to be judged
as such
um so what does the prime minister need
to do we know that kia stamina is
literally hot footing it up to batley
and spend to congratulate
the new mp what does the prime minister
have to do
the prime minister has to do undertake a
detailed analysis
with people from conservative central
office to find out why the conservatives
didn't quite take a seat which was
previously labor held
look at the messaging look at
the general impression that the
government has at the moment
clearly the parties in the lead overall
in national opinion polls
so it's not in that bad a position but
it needs to
review as it should whenever you get
what is a disappointment but not a
disaster
and as far as the hancock affair is
concerned we heard from the co-chair
saying that the matter's closed
how do you think that is going to play
out with the public
well i think i've heard interviews
overnight of
people and this morning of people going
back to work in the factories in badly
and spent
saying that's another matter i think
people have moved on from it now
that's not something that uh he's going
to run and run and run
there's an element of upset that there
was quite naturally
because the decision should have been
taken earlier um but
we now move on and we've got uh
hopefully we've got freedom day on the
19th of july
so people's general lives will move on
so there doesn't need to be an
investigation into the appropriation of
public funds
i'm not i didn't say that it was a
question at the end it was a question at
the end
my intonation didn't yeah
my apologies no you clearly got to
look into any question that people
raise validly and and answer them and
that's true of government and in
opposition
okay we must let you go lord hayward um
it's good to talk to you this morning
thanks for taking the time come in and
see us next time
i would love to i'm looking forward to
being back in the studio
yeah we're looking forward to having you
thank you thank you
thanks a lot a quick look at the weather
phenom here's nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning low pressure out in the
atlantic we'll be bringing some rather
unsettled conditions into this weekend
with heavy showers expected as well as
more persistent spells of rain
and stronger winds developing across
some parts of the south until then it's
not too bad for today
there's still going to be some wet
weather around and in fact it's quite
cloudy and foggy this morning with some
rain across southeastern parts of
scotland northeast england and some
eastern england
areas as well most that rain will tend
to fade away but into this afternoon
we'll see bright or sunny spells
developing but some heavy showers
around eastern parts of wales in
particular the midlands central and
eastern england
northern england southern scotland some
of them could be heavy in sundry
particularly for southeast scotland
northeast england then later rain from
the southwest spreading northeastwards
overnight
the weather sponsored by qatar airways